welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spider-man and with
spider-man now officially out of the MCU
I thought it was time to look to the
future and see all of the options that
Sony has with the character as well as
where they could go down the line
throughout this video I'll be discussing
where the film franchise could be going
off of all the information that we have
on sony's upcoming projects and giving
my thoughts on what the best play is
these options all pretty much suck but
hey what can you do other than hash tag
raid Sony instead of area 51 maybe we
should just pray for a night monkey
movie and everything will be alright
anyway without the way I just want to
give a huge thank you for clicking this
video now let's get into the breakdown
of what's next for spider-man the next
film and the franchise will be the
Morbius movie this is set to release on
July 31st of 2020 and will have Jared
Leto at the helm the announcement of
Morbius was quite head scratching for me
as the character has never really been
all that popular even in the
spider-verse
and it seems like a weird thing to try
and launch a franchise with there have
been examples in the past though such as
guardians of the galaxy which Sodhi less
characters become a listers and Sony are
clearly trying to launch the villain in
order to create what I think will be the
sinister six with spider-man now fully
back at Sony I can see the character
appearing in a post-credits scene that
will tie together the universe slightly
after he was missing from venom which
leads me into my next point from here I
think we will likely get our first fully
fleshed out spider-man far from home
sequel that will follow the character as
he deals with being outed by Mysterio
one of the biggest overlooked aspects of
the sony disney deal is that we did get
confirmation from it that Tom Holland is
definitely going to be in at least two
solo spider-man movies going forward it
should be relatively easy for Sony to
just pick up from where the character
left off but whether they are able to
deliver on all aspects with characters
like happy Hogan Nick Fury and so on
missing will be interesting to see it
doesn't even seem like the name Tony
Stark can be said
the film and he of course had a huge
impact on spider-man's life though some
closure was delivered in far from home
how he will go on to be the next Iron
Man when Iron Man doesn't exist will be
interesting to see and there are rumors
that the next solo spider-man villain
will be Kraven the hunter who similar to
Morbius and venom is getting a solo film
this is apparently being written by
equalizer to Rider
Richard went and it makes a lot of sense
for Kraven who is a big-game hunter to
be going after spider-man in an upcoming
film I'm very curious to see if Sony can
keep up the momentum of the MCU without
the larger world connected to it but I
guess we'll see next up is venom 2 we
know that this is in development as
Annie Circus was recently confirmed as
the film's director and after the
post-credits scene of the prior film it
seems that Sony have a plan to have
carnage go head-to-head with the
character it's up in the air whether
this will be released before or after
spider-man 3 and this will likely change
how the events play out reviews for
venom were pretty mixed and whilst the
film did do well theatrically especially
in China I think that the company have
to be smarter than before perhaps having
Tom Holland actually feature in the film
this could potentially be because
spider-man has had to flee from New York
to San Francisco due to his identity
being exposed and far from home and
there's definitely ways that they can
bring the universes together with
Holland free to feature in crossover
films now I can definitely see Sony
using this as an opportunity to bring
him across fully into the universe there
were rumors that venom 3 will be maximum
carnage and potentially the second movie
will introduce spider-man and form the
team together before they go and fight
head-to-head with the titular villain
either way this is one of the films that
I'm most interested in seeing going
forward as it's pretty much going to
show how spider-man will interact with
the other characters in the Sony verse
which I'm sure everyone is curious about
if we do get a craving solar film then I
think that the next logical step to take
is a sinister six movie with Mysterio
scorpion vulture Kraven venom and a
newly introduced villain at the helm
Sony have in the past try to create
sinister six film and this was hinted at
in the amazing spider-man 2 though they
severely dropped the ball with it this
is the most obvious direction for Sony
to be heading in
it will create their own shared universe
and I'd put money on us getting a
sinister six phone within the next 10
years
and lastly movie wise is the
spider-verse franchise Sony will no
doubt want to create another film in
this series as the film won the Oscar
for best animation and was well received
across the board the only did it open up
the multiverse but it also introduced
Miles Morales who is now an extremely
popular character Sony are now able to
use Tom Holland as a voice actor in this
franchise and they could potentially
bring him across the multiverse into
this movie to interact with the
characters with what will no doubt be a
much-anticipated movie I think the
spider-verse really gave Sony the
confidence to go in their own direction
and in my opinion this is one of the
main reasons that the Sony and Disney
deal fell apart
now second-to-last is the spider-man TV
series which Phil Lord and Chris Miller
are currently developing this news was
announced in the last week and with a
little hindsight you can see that Sony
were probably gearing up to part ways
with Disney and thus began working on
this I think the broken-down deal has
been like this for a while and this is
why we didn't see spider-man as part of
the face for lineup at San Diego
comic-con Sony were initially planning
to do a black cat and silver sable film
when amazing spider-man 2 was in
development so it makes sense that they
would now adapt these characters to the
upcoming shows who knows what will
happen with this and there are even
rumors that Sony may be setting up a
streaming service with this being the
launch pad of it though this remains
unsubstantiated at the moment and the
final option which is the one that I
hope happens is that Sony realized
they've messed up they see the internet
outcry and decide to go back to Disney
to renegotiate the deal I basically want
Kevin Feige to be like you couldn't live
with your failure so where has that
brought you back to me I think going
back is definitely the best thing for
the fans and probably despite a man
franchise as a can see interest waning
in it if it's not connected to the
overall universe Tony Stark it didn't
die for this and it's baffling that Sony
will completely take spider-man off the
table especially with how much goodwill
should be built up between the companies
due to their shared success whether this
happens or not we will see but it's the
one I'm pulling for the most obviously
I'd love to hear your thoughts on the
future of spider-man so make sure that
you leave them in the
section below if you enjoyed this video
then please like it and make sure you
check out my full reaction to the
original spider-man Sony news which we
linked at the end I go over all of the
ins and outs of the deal so it's
definitely worth watching if you want to
know more if you want to come talk to me
about movies TV shows games and comic
books and you can follow me on twitter
at definition YT it's the best way to
get in touch with me and it's the
perfect place to suggest new videos and
content well so just wanna let you know
that we're giving away a free copy of
John with three on blu-ray and all you
have to do to be in with a chance of
winning is to like this video make sure
that you subscribe to the channel and
leave your thoughts on the spider-verse
going forward in the comments section
below the woman will be chosen at random
on September the 10th and the blu-ray
will be shipped out from then to ever
get surprised it's the best of luck that
everyone who takes part this is a
channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]